دي صوره من واشنطن
لتجمد المياه همم هناك طبعا ليست واشنطن
وحدها هي التي تشهد هذه الاحوال احوال
الطقس البروده الرياح الثلوج الامطار ولكن
العديد من الولايات خاصه في الشرق وولايات
وسط الغرب ورغمى كل ذلك كانت الارصاد
الجويه توقعت ان يتحسن الطقس في هذه
الولايات بعد ايام من البرد القارس همم
نتيجه العاصفه التي وصفت بعاصفه القرن
والتي اودت بحياه اكثر من 50 شخصا على
الاقل واحدث فوضى كبرى في حركه السفر خلال
عطل اعياد الميلاد وراس السنه ونتابع
واياكم هذه الصور اذا التي تريدون من
واشنطن اضافه الى جانب اخر من الصوره في
همم في ولايه نيويورك اضافه الى الصوره
الاخرى من داخل احد مطارات خلاص اذا من
العديد من المناطق كانت لا تزال تحت تاثير
العاصفه خاصه في بافلو في نيويورك مع
تساقط كثيف همم
للثلوج والعثور على جثث في داخل بعض
السيارات وتحت الثلوج مع تفقد عناصر
الاغاثه المزيد من السيارات بحثا عن ناجين
اذن هذه البحيره هي البحيره المطله على
نصب بواسطه
مياه هذه البحيره وهذه صور خاصه بها جر
عاصفه
القرن كثر عاده ما يلجاؤنا الى التزلج على
مياه البحيرات
في الغرب عندما تتجمد في فصل الشتاء نتيجه
البروده
القارصه كما يحصل الان اذا في العاصمه
الامريكيه وفي عدد من الولايات الامريكيه
همم الاخرى اذا كانت الارصاد تحدثت همم عن
تحسن احوال الطقس في الايام المقبله ولكن
ضلت الدعوات لامكانيه همم او الدعوات
للحذر من السفر الى بعض المناطق هناك بسبب
هذه الاحوال